heavy rains have caused some of the
worst flooding in two decades in parts
of bangladesh and india at least 57
people have been killed and 2 million
left stranded in northeastern bangladesh
floods are not a new phenomenon during
monsoon season but experts say climate
change is making them more dangerous
bangladesh is prone to flooding
but this is the worst many have seen in
nearly 20 years
hundreds of villagers in the north east
have been inundated
creating hardship and misery for more
than two million people
we're surviving by putting one bed on
top of another half of our homestead is
underwater
if the water rises we don't know what
we'll do
my chickens are all dead i don't have
any boat to bring food from elsewhere
the situation came to a head
when a major river burst its banks after
days of torrential rain
and an onrush of flood waters from
neighboring india
tens of thousands are now without power
shelter or enough to eat
but even when these waters recede
people's problems will be far from
these farmers are trying to dry their
crops on the road after their fields
were submerged
i've only managed to harvest one third
of my rice paddy from under the
water the rest was washed away
it's been two weeks since there was any
sun
all that extra rain has devastated
whatever i've managed to collect
i'm unable to dry it out it's rotting
it's a terrible situation
thousands of people hit by the floods
are living in shelters
many have lost everything
and it's unclear
if and when they will be able to return
to their homes